Ralph's mouth and temper frequently
created problems he coldly killed his
stripper girlfriend Tracy his bad
influence helped lead Jackie apprel Jr
to his death in short Ralph was just the
worst and was killed in the season 4
episode whoever did this while he felt
horrible about his son that didn't stop
Ralph from burning down the stable that
contained a racehorse co-owned by Tony
and him when Tony talked to him about it
and Ralph more or less confessed to it
Tony went into a rage what followed was
the essence of the Panos in many ways an
awkward ugly visceral fight that was
uncomfortable to watch Tony eventually
strangled Ralph and slammed his head
into the floor to kill him he and
Christopher then spent a long time
chopping him up and disposing of the
body